We have the pleasure of
speaking with Paul Ekman,
who's going to share his perspective
on the evolution of emotion and whether
emotions are culturally universal.
So Dr. Paul Ekman is a professor emeritus
of psychology at the University of
California San Francisco and has authored
or edited 13 books most recently as we
showed earlier in the course
emotions revealed. Um,
and he's also the coauthor with the
Dalai Lama on emotional awareness,
overcoming the obstacles to
psychological balance and compassion.
Paul Ekman has consulted with federal
and law, local law enforcement,
national security,
corporate sales and negotiations,
health and education professionals
and animators at some of the largest
animations Siri studios in the world.
Um,
some of you might know the show lie to
me and he was one of the consultants
there to sort of teach them how to detect
a facial expressions of emotion being
also the founder of the
facial action coding system,
which we talked about
earlier in the course. Um,
Paul Ekman has received
countless awards and honors.
I couldn't even list all of them today.
Some of them include the distinguished
scientific contribution award from the
American Psychological Association.
And his work has been discussed in the
New York Times. Washington Post, some,
some Smithsonian magazine
psychology today,
and the New Yorker Time magazine not
surprisingly selected him as one of the
hundred most influential people in 2009.
Um,
he's appeared on numerous sort
of media outlets as well, uh,
for live interviews including 48 hours,
dateline.
Good Morning America,
2020 Larry King, Oprah,
Johnny Carson, and many
other TV programs. Um,
so it's an honor today to have this
amazing experts in emotion interview with
what is perhaps the founder of emotion
as we know it today with Dr. Paul Ekman
discussing the topic of our
emotions culturally universal.
So welcome Doctor Ekman.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
You know, as really the pioneer that
got the study of emotion, you know,
put on the map in the first place.
I'd love to hear a bit about,
for you, what got you interested
in studying this topic?
Sort of how did you come about to
land on the science of human emotion?
Yeah,
better than maybe the true reason cause
I don't know that we always know the
reasons or choices.
A long time ago and I was an undergraduate
that goes back to the
1950 [inaudible] early.
I thought that the answers are the
world's hills was psychotherapy
you really important places.
Individual psychotherapy we would
take to the law was group therapy,
just getting pretty popular.
And so I started observing through a
one way mirror therapy sessions and the
issue wasn't forced high would prove its
effectiveness and the only tools around
for measuring what people were doing
and group therapy dealt with their words
but only one person speaks at a time.
But the others react with your posture,
with your gaze,
facial expression and this is
being ignored. And I thought, gee,
we need to measure that if we're really
going to improve the effectiveness of
therapy.
So all take on developing the methods
and the concepts for dealing with what I
then call non verbal behavior.
Everything other than the speech itself.
And a little did I realize as I started,
you know how there wasn't much there,
there weren't tools already
available that could be employed.
I would have to develop the tools and
there wasn't much conceptually it was very
relevant.
Um,
after eight or 10 years I
found Sylvan Tompkins and, uh,
he gave me a lot of help in showing me
where he was getting me information face.
But his theory I didn't find very useful.
So it was a lot to do.
But I liked that because it was an empty,
pretty much empty field.
Uh,
and so there wasn't a lot of the kind
of rivalry and backbiting that often
occurs in hunter fields
in psychology. And, uh,
also it meant using cameras and I was
making half my living when I first got my
phd as a photographer.
And so the idea of bringing
the two together, uh,
I'd use cameras to understand
people. I liked that. And also,
and it became clear that in order to
sell the most fundamental question,
which is,
is not her behavior,
a culture specific language,
lung phenomenon or is it more
product or our evolution?
We're biologically, if he was in
universal in order to answer that,
you'd have to travel for a lot
of different places. Oh my God.
I wanted to travel and
so I bought g Agri News.
Cameras are getting to travel and nobody's
going to be competing with me because
at best, I mean actually I was told
repeatedly you're wasting your time.
There's not the year. That was the
opinion of academics psychology.
The former head of NSF,
we recently also retired as
head of all 10 UC systems.
Told me the 1960s don't you know,
this is a dead end.
Why are you wasting your time with it?
I recently saw him and he said, Oh,
who were the suspected that you
are able to certainly not yet
have you start off by clinicians.
They knew eras information there.
Uh,
not the accurate in sorrow
and those days and I made,
she was willing to take a risk.
I was doing high risk research area.
No one hit.
So far we've been successful.
Have you support for 30 years.
Every grant that I wrote was worth it.
Hmm.
That's an amazing story because I mean,
since then,
I mean your work has just been pioneering
in developing what we know to be the
most, you know, rigorous and widely
used tool for coding, you know,
expressions of human emotion in the face,
you know,
your facial action coding system.
Um,
and I wonder if you could say a little
bit more about the development of this
system,
sort of what,
what were the first initial steps and
what do you see as some of the most
important applications
of this coding system?
Low is a giant task to undertake and I
didn't want to be cognitive of you taking
it if I read your license or degree
eight years, cause I got one,
I only had a grant for five years,
I thought I'd get done from start to
finish five years. Silver talkers.
So I mean not to charge to Prophylax
I've ever succeed and yeah.
Uh,
after our one major false start,
uh,
I realize that what you're seeing is
really a mechanical system and their
muscles underneath that skin and those
muscles are pulling the skin from one
place to another.
And if you can learn the anatomy and
how these muscles are creating each
expression,
you could dissect the expression it
just from looking at video or film,
you don't need to average the faceless.
Ooh.
Uh, so you had your truck
freezing and our reason,
and I worked together 25 years,
we were just recently cars learning
about how did we managed to work together
for 25 years and I can argue very clear
division of labor of who did what work
beautifully.
At the end of five years I was nearly
out of money and I was almost there.
All right. [inaudible] take one more
year and I wrote her a big move.
It's already be in there.
Imh three years, 20 years.
And they said, ah, no more honey. Oh No.
See you didn't build this.
Doulas talk down.
We're not going to put what we've are
starting to put more money into it
just by accident.
I was contact.
Why Robin,
you lion or tiger who then we're
running a small foundation,
this small Guggenheim
Foundation and they called me.
I haven't fostered were in town. Your
work. We'd like to give you some money.
This is why I'm tired. I said her mom,
you are, you're pulling quite late.
Tiger walks if you want
to give me no, no, no.
They said we're really serious. So really
you just for a drink down charm? I did.
And they gave you that money.
He should get it.
Justin drove a block. I'd be wise, I
would have been hanging out a shingle.
They tried to do psychotherapy,
which I doc activity somehow.
Yeah. It's amazing how much happens
just by serendipity. Like you're,
you're telling him that story.
You guys,
I was a,
I asked her a few years ago or do you
give a truck to the medical students about
my career? I was the first year this
all I science to see if it's successful.
The Korea and I titled the Jaw
Zera Deputy Perseverance a time.
That was,
I said,
we're in order for any one of those
less than figure out how you're going to
turtle. So things fell into my lap. Oh,
why did I start with this? I got
back from uh, the work in your day.
It was an hour afterwards.
Solid evidence for the fact that Darwin
really was right around expression.
I use your gestures or not are totally
different. They're a coaches specifically.
Russians seem to be universal
issue. Sir, I taught she,
we've gotta be able,
or Tom kids can go up to the screen and
show me where are you as needing anger,
where he was the fear I should be
able to develop an, which is awesome.
So that was the inspiration and I didn't
realize how hard it was going to be,
how long it was going to change.
And yet it still remains the gold standard
and it's a lot of progress has now on
automating it.
If you use facts,
you know you are about an hour to
score one minute if you behave.
So it's a slow process are very precise.
Well,
soon a 70 or 80% of what
people do get scored.
That would be a big time saver.
Being a fax coder myself, you know,
you'd be a big truck.
Is all little movies left for you or
the things that the carding automated
cutting systems having problems.
So it'll hop down,
uh,
more risk and increase the number
of people who are using facts.
Am I colleague Robert Levinson.
We'll do hard collaborating or years
looking at the relationship that you
express your physiology,
awkward cheese and iceberg says that's
going to really beat you bad cause then
all equal,
we're in a rush and her started using
vaccines will be a lot of trashy research
right now the people will use facts
after the very committed because it's a
process.
So I wanted to ask you then,
what do you see as some of
the applications of facts
both within the laboratory
and outside the laboratory and these kind
of real world applications that I know
you've been taking a
large part in as well?
Well, we've developed separate tools, uh,
for people who watch to
spot it seals emotion.
And
you're here to learn facts.
You don't taste with your 50 and
900 hours to learn the first five,
since I've retired and not your two hours,
you've been marked your recognize
conceals emotions. Uh, that's an injury.
I'm sure 109,000 people.
I've learned it already.
We just want our line and Margaret people
from all over the world with all kinds
of purposes in my back's
remains and the researchers
for example,
how many synonyms are there drag or uh,
we know there are a lot of different
ways over 80 different ways show anger.
Well, what's your, those are relevant.
Just sulking. Which Jane indignation,
which do exacerbation,
which their Curie,
which an annoyance and how many of them
show a type of Agora that we don't have
here.
We have to name shine.
You only have a functional words
for different types of Agora.
That's your anymore expressions.
So are they expressions just simply
synonyms or are they naming things that we
have not given her words or words
or representations of emotion?
They're not an emotion.
I think his argument with other people
in the field or the people who are you
with me? I stopped arguing
rocks. I answered the device.
That's actually, but there are people
who were really concerned with the words.
Really each emotion has its own
narrative and underlying store.
So anger has to do with protecting
yourself against threats or insults there.
That has to do with it in some way.
That's the underlying story.
I was very,
very different than the underlying story
of sadness switches has to do with it
this morning.
Hmm.
It should be just, there are many
reasons why you could be disappointed.
You're going to be disappointed
in yourself that you
didn't really act the way
you wish you had active.
You can be disappointed via a lover who
rejects you are fat you year to get an
article published.
There are many different ways,
but they all have to
do with disappointment,
feeling sort of lovely rejection.
At least that's the same story.
So to represent our emotions
with a single word like sadness,
anger, seals, a lot of these differences
have facts, measures everything.
You could do yours in anything you can
do with a very slick blacks can't give
you a way of describing
and then it's up to us,
the scientists to find out
what these things sick.
Why in the world with nature give us
80 different ways of displaying anger.
He were all senators be waste of time.
We have to do with different nuances
and those would be interesting too.
I've covered. All right. Another thing I'm
most interested in at the moment, yeah,
is a great long shot Andy North for
some shot because it's such a long shot,
although it happy,
nervous benefit,
say Mars are so far from the last 10
years have not been able to get any
government agency to support it.
Maybe they will.
I was a recent event that's this tragic
event I had a kid has made violence arch
were saying,
so what I'm interested in and what
I have some leads for is what it,
is there a signal that warns
us of impending violence?
Is there something you can see 20 or
30 seconds before the violence versus
stripes orange you hear about too,
if there was
intervention,
say bars,
you can save the life of the violent
person because most of these people been
themselves after they go go.
What do you see as some of the potential
hypotheses about what might be some of
the micro expressions that might occur
immediately before violent behavior
strikes?
Yes.
Reservists game here,
but you go more than a
hundred assassination.
If you're someone who was shooting the
arteries that should even be heard.
Your camper either a hamburger or a
newsperson and then suddenly a weapon and
fears her stripes and it's,
I could see the expression on his face
or I try 20 surgeons, the borders,
the same expression,
scattered reports drop serious crime,
five country Western, aren't you?
Sorry, I have some really good leads.
I'm not going to tell you what
they are because I am not certain.
I want those who are,
you know what it is they need to
suppress. Sure. Well, let me ask, I ask
a question about something
you brought up earlier,
which is you're really groundbreaking
work on the universality of emotion
expressions and recognition of emotions
and I wonder if you could describe what
some of these initial insights were in
your early work that really gave you
clues to,
as you said,
that Darwin was really on to something
in his initial observations of emotion
expressions.
Well,
just by luck,
I ran into a program officer
and the Defense Department,
what was that called?
The advanced research projects agency,
and he was married to a woman from
Thailand and they were having some marital
problems and he thought maybe they were
misunderstanding each other's emotions
and expressions. So he said to
me, I wasn't liked to go out find.
What's your, is it Brittany that
universal or is it all culture specific?
I want you to do basic research on this.
I'll give you as much
money as you need and uh,
find out Margaret mead writers,
Darwin, right? Or are they both? Right.
So we have a proposal in the next week
or a video dollars sounds right now this
was 1960 $5 is all lot of 65,
it would be like 10 to 20 million now.
So I went back,
is that what you start? I started, I of
you called me and he said, where's the
proposal? I said, I'm not going to do it.
He says, I'll see you
tomorrow. [inaudible] sister.
And he wrote the proposal.
So I then talked to all of
the experts I already do to.
I got Margaret needs to be willing
to talk to me. She wasn't very here.
I talked to her, talked to her,
well I talked to Charles Oscar,
you watch the dude there thing that you
really need to do is you need to find
division.
We isolated group couldn't have been
influenced by the media or our son.
And by a stroke of luck I sound medical
scientists who had been working with a
isolated group,
the beginning,
find out what was causing
a grain disease. Cool. Kurt
[inaudible] and he had been
wise enough to recognize it.
As important as the work he was doing is
just documenting life in the stone age
option.
So he hired a fulltime cinematographer
and he shot [inaudible] shot a hundred
thousand feet,
just social life.
I of course he had never looked
at Dr. Thompson fee and he said,
we want to take a look,
I'll give you a cop.
So sock checked her coffee recently and
I spent a year so I was ahead of all of
this.
So that's true.
And that's where I found out
with a story where I was,
because I never saw an
expression I hadn't seen before.
If he was the right guy, I should
see things on a basis I'd never see.
And when I could tell from happened
before or afterwards in the episode,
my interpretation was right.
So no one's going to hold the
year was the proof. But that's,
I can't put that film and
drew take Earth Science,
I have to figure out how can I
possibly do research on this.
And I went to this medical
designers and I said,
I want to come to your area a new day
and look at these people and figure out
what kind of experiment I can do.
Why? And he said it. So I went,
I had funds. Do you do
anything I wanted? I got
the funds if that were administered by
the state of California and they wanted
her to receive her. Every penny
was, it was smacking. And I said,
these people don't have their free lyric.
They don't write check at your receipts.
I have to get a lesson.
We would a project from a Buddha doctor,
you won't be off to the writer of
seafood here. All hard material goods.
So I went to Johnson and robbed the
first time the evidence was not there.
I was telling stories to
these people and asked them
point that first year to do that,
I would show them a photograph of him.
Emotion.
I've never seen her photograph before.
I had no trouble recognizing they
had never seen her newer. Hmm.
Really
attraction. Sorry. Sure, sure.
All right, so tell me the story.
What was happening before?
What's after you now?
What else you could see square
ordering off the I want,
I've never asked them to
do such a strange thing.
It's not like it's story about this thing
that they'd never seen before and they
recognize me.
They record black making after the stories
and when I got the stories and their
stories were a reasonably consistent
reach your emotion, right.
I didn't have a big sample.
Hated doing.
So I did publish the results in science,
but they weren't really robust and they
were based really on 30 40 50 feet.
I came back here like,
God I just did or how to crack this,
that by luck I remembered a paper.
I read rise apologist for
drop job Dashiell if he had
worked for three and four
year olds,
are they going to have a written by?
So it was his idea.
Where he would do is he read
shogun couple of photographs,
each run of a different emotion.
He was telling of the story,
why are these people is
out to fight friction?
One of these people or
a child who's pitching,
what are these goofballs see brands.
And we really liked working with
Christian Arthur. Oh my God, he's,
so I went back to New Guinea and I use
that procedure and we got closer jolts
shoulder and we got almost
10% of your child culture.
Or of course I went back
the second time they do,
I was just a harmless person
and the word 50 strike,
this was really easy. And I give
them a bar of soap. You're going to
bars,
sir.
So people I didn't have
to hike to remote villages
and every morning stood online
basketball and then they were off.
So it was wonderful.
Now why formulation is how sure
her VA's even single system.
And so it influences exactly what triggers
the emotion and influence is what I
call the spray rules.
The chimps advantage in most instances
it already [inaudible] how are you your
attitudes about having recently,
uh,
edge what you're likely to do?
So it isn't,
this is a response is
culture plays no role what it is,
right or wrong overlay on
a universal signal system.
Charles Darwin's word.
Sure.
Oh Man.
So as someone who's been a pioneer and
really understanding human emotion and
extent to which it says,
you're saying universal and then having
this veneer of cultural influence above
it, where do you see the future
of emotion going from here,
sort of on the horizon?
What's next?
No,
I'm not a good forecast.
I didn't write everything just sort of
dropped into my lap. It isn't, is it hard?
Well,
what's the most important for you?
Do you understand the nature of
impression or you have to actually take
advantage of opportunities. So it's
really good. Japan with the opportunities,
I believe that we should stop spending
so much time showing people emotion.
And Archie measure emotional
behavior and you need to get out.
It's not as if this is
something of term three years.
I tried to get people
to go to the funerals.
I never was able to bring just a
student. She had arose. Weddings,
confirmations are all of these type of
situations. Correct. Tense, emotional,
just raising sure as well as it
first in the bedroom and the kitchen.
It's harder to get in there,
but still you can.
John Gottman is a friend or colleague
for many years studying marijuana
directions where a steady
apples are having trouble. Uh,
he's also studied couples
who are having trouble.
It's not that they don't have
disagreements. Every one of your chapters,
disagreement seat.
Yeah.
Or even very lucky person doesn't mean
you're going to agree with him about
every aspect of how to live your
lives together and separate.
But the issue is how you
handle those disabilities.
Your handles them out.
Uh,
anger your answer anyway.
Harmful.
No, I've developed a new online
tools to try to help people do that.
It's called mapping your anger.
Rough law to go through it.
You're just rubber by moving.
Spiders are cuter screening the unique
ways in which you experience and how that
differs or ready to
work as it should have.
You can look at each other and
how you perceive each other.
That should be online I April or, right.
Fantastic. I'm sure a lot of couples
will find that a useful tool.
It is. It's fun. Also, if it isn't fun,
you're no longer has to be enjoyable.
As it says tedious,
I'm learning vocabulary
or foreign language.
That's just memorization.
Really tedious thing. Yeah.
Uh Huh.
Learning about emotion,
raw motivated. Let's take,
we would most likely be able to do
this to be able to chew.
What would you be comfortable sharing
about and choose how we behave would be
our approach now. Nature didn't want
you to have either of those choices,
so you respond
most people and you respond
not necessarily the way
that it's going to be most
useful to this situation.
What's built into you?
What was really useful in
living in a tribal society?
We don't anymore. We live in
very, very different contexts,
so, but there are skills. Oh,
did she can learn her.
Describing one of my books were the
exercises and you're actually booger.
You'll start to increase
your awareness of emotion.
You're having the emotion. Just to realize
afterwards, oh my God, I lost my head.
You say I lost my head.
What are you saying?
You're saying my head
was not really involved.
I wasn't really funny to show my emotions
running the show and I only got in
afterwards.
Are you willing to give you right
at the beginning you want from her?
Recognize that involves
the trauma emotional and be
able to choose wherever you
want to act on Azure and dry.
My last [inaudible] who was the Dalai
Lama calls emotional awareness events.
She is awareness.
It's early in the episode as you can
and that will require it worked on.
It is your dog new exercises and new
brain circuitry that will allow you to
monitor what you're actually doing as
you're doing it and you will develop are
what the Buddhists call a watcher part
of yourself that is observing yourself.
Then you're a lot more choice.
This is what we go a lot.
So when you talk about learning
emotion and you know twice as well,
I mean these are important questions
that students or people in the community
who want to learn more about emotion
might come and ask you about how can I
learn more about emotion or what choices
do I have, any emotions I experienced?
And what kind of advice do you give people
who come to you asking about how can
I get involved in wanting to study this?
You know,
fascinating but complex and sometimes
ambiguous phenomena. That's emotion.
Well,
there's a number of things you could read
their jewels, you get Jake, then
we'll make you a more acute observer.
I've just putting another online
training tool that helps you learn how to
respond to what others versus
emotions in the most effective, right?
Cause this is my to know now
you're concealing it. Perfect.
All right, you're not
supposed to work. We're,
how do I respond to
that most effective way?
And this new tool teaches
you how to do that.
So we can teach you online
how to recognize the emotion.
Either respond to it,
but what we don't yet have an online,
more water is working on it.
She's here.
Your Phd
is developing their momentary
awareness as the impulse psoriasis.
I, for some of us, that's going
to be a really easy for us.
You have her brother's gradual slope of
emotional arousal and your others are
lucky attack dogs of emotion.
They go from zero to maximum.
That's going to be much harder.
It's paradoxical,
but people need to learn. This is the
most or argued the hardest so far.
He goes, let's go to their
system is fast responding.
Didn't say you're merged,
your moderated,
so they'll have more chores. Those
are exercises, those exercises.
All right.
I like to use the example of chairs or
you can even watch the game of tennis on
TV.
Any sense of it?
If you don't know the rules and you
could read with the rows are 10 or 15
minutes on our,
everything you need you to have that
will make you a good observer. Okay?
Where'd you won't care it while over in
the hat for that practice and the coach,
she's trying
why little copy read their book
shops to drug each that we ever,
or some emotional skills.
It's four days long.
There's a lot of exercising and I practice
jade brown or it's like getting your
GP, you get the ball longer
than that in immersion snaps.
It gives you all the tools you'll need,
which if you Virginia to use the really
increasingly have choice about your
emotional.
That's what we're really lucky.
Well,
I mean this has been wonderful speaking
with you as someone who so revered in
the field and I know many,
many people including myself were inspired
by when I was first a young student
thinking about, you know, trying
to understand what emotions were.
So I just want to thank you so much
doctor acne for speaking today and being
part of this series
pleasure.
You know,
I frown that injuries are really enjoyable
is you have a smart interviewer asks
great questions. If you
did, you'd be deadly.
Someone hasn't done their homework or
just know how to ask the questions ready.
It's April process, but this,
as you can probably see,
I like talking about this area of work.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so this will conclude our experts in
emotion interview with Dr. Paul Ekman from
the University of California,
San Francisco and the Paul Ekman Group.